let's bring back Newt Gingrich to
discuss the GOP prospects which seem to
be improving in November new thoughts
well I think that the Republicans are
likely to gain four to six seats in the
Senate I think there are six seats we're
hearing they could they could lose the
majority in the Senate six months ago I
do a newsletter at Gingrich productions
that goes out twice a week for free and
two weeks ago I wrote everybody who was
wrong in the spring of 16 who said Trump
couldn't be the nominee was everybody
who was wrong in the fall of 16 who said
Trump couldn't win the presidency are
the same people are on TV right now
why would you believe any of them but
Steve Schmidt has been so right you know
that work over the years all of the I
say facetiously all of the political
analyst establishment and the Talking
Heads have a bias of getting together
and saying this is what's going to
happen now if I were a Democrat and I
looked at that poll today from Reuters
the Republicans are up one where they
used to be down ten or eleven fifteen
and one time you know I'd begin to panic
because if the Republicans are anywhere
close to even on the generic they they
could conceivably gain seats doesn't
impeachment hurt the Democrats because
the Republicans when you see them turn
out still for these rallies for Trump
Newt you've seen these people well
people think impeachment they're gonna
go out to the polls I hope that guy says
the impeachment congressman green I
thought it was Al Green suddenly Al
Green got into politics but it's another
congressman but he he said we're going
to impeach the president articles of
impeachment that's gonna drive
Republicans right to the polls so it's
not Democrat sometimes no that's not
just the Trump supporters the average
American who's not deeply political
wants the system to work they love
what's happening with the economy they
love the fact that we have the lowest
unemployment rate in modern times they
think it's terrific Gallup just reported
65% of the country think so that you can
get a good job highest number since they
began taking that question and so
they're sitting there going let me get
this straight
the Democrats voted knowing the tax cuts
and would now like to totally screw up
the economy
by chasing an impeachment on a topic
that doesn't seem to have any substance
they got prison reform passed through
the House today that's a huge bipartisan
big victory huge bipartisan issue that
likely passed the Senate you got the
part of the dodd-frank repealed that's
happening you got all these judges to me
one judges on the circuit courts getting
through I mean this is good stuff and
you see really unusual things I mean you
you end up looking at you know Van Jones
Liberal Democrat shows up at the White
House as part of prison reform something
you couldn't have seen a hearing I think
the Kanye West effect is something we
still haven't seen full effect is a
second example me Kanye West within
three days
black support approval of Trump jumped
from eleven to twenty two freaking them
and one how much of an increase in
african-american support for for the
president or the Republican agenda would
just devastate the Democrats like a five
thousand five or eight or nine percent
would be devastating if they if the
Republicans ever get to twenty percent
of the black vote it is virtually
impossible for the Democrats to survive
that's what they are truly petrified of
that and that's there could be racism
racism racism that's gonna within
identity politics right right and at the
same time well you have though is a
president who can say absolutely
accurately this is the best situation in
black unemployment in American history
never been lower so II think it's a
great time to be an American right now I
mean I mean if you're in business I mean
what the cultists lots of stuff happen
in the culture that I'm not wild about
but as far as Economic Opportunity the
whole range of innovation and
technological opportunity I'm trying to
figure out how to get every eighth
grader this September to understand
literally they have a chance to go to
the moon they have a chance to go to
Mars the world the this stuff is
changing so fast young people out ever
since they're gonna live one of the most
exciting generations in history and that
could be part of Trump's greatest legacy
optimism and positivity Pelosi and
Schumer just to give you one more cell
on the better deal motto Newt let's
watch you mean instead of delivering on
its promise
to drain the swamp President Trump has
become the swamp we want Republicans and
their corrupt big donor driven agenda to
get out of the way it has given the
American people a raw deal President
Trump when it comes to draining the
swamp has been a complete and total
disappointment this swamp has never been
more foul or more fetid than under this
president dude I know you love the fact
you use the word fetid I know that's
what you were saying first of all the
idea that we now have Democrats talking
about the swamp
it's an enormous psychological victory
second the three top Democrats in the
House between them are 278 years old
this is the base of their campaign this
fall vote for people who haven't who've
been around so long they know nothing
you don't date them Newt you carbon date
them
all right great always